فتحته المنازل في بلده كميانكا في ضواحي
ايزيوم لم تعد تقتصر على ابوابه ونوافذه
فسكانها يحاولون حصر الاضرار دون جدوى لا
اسقف يحتمون بها ولا ابواب تقيم شر الخارج
والاخشاب التي تهاوت عده الشتاء الذي حل
عليهم قاسيا كما القذائف خلال سيطره
القوات الروسيه عليها
500 منزلا تضررت او دمرت تماما بسبب
المعارك فيما الافتقار الى مواد البناء
ونقص العماله جعل الاصلاحات مستبعده مع
قرب انخفاض درجات الحراره الى ما دون درجه
التجمد في الايام المقبله وفي وقت غادر
معظم سكان القريه البالغ عددهم الفا 1200
سنه يخطط الباقون للالتفاف حول الشتاء
لتكون اكوام صناديق الذخيره التي خلفتها
القوات الروسيه المنسحبه
خيار الانسب كحطب للتدفئه وايضا جدران
مؤقته
انقطاع متزايد للتيار الكهربائي ترك هذه
القريه الصغيره وسكانها في عتمه بارده